I [ __ ] shite itte chef - oh my [ __ ]
god that horrible we don't look like
that and Scotland hello all out Babel a
switch Capaldi here and today I'm gonna
be playing
snack was I'll be tasting some of the
best snacks from from Scotland and from
England and I'll be telling you which
reigns supreme
I don't know what either of these things
are I mean that's looks like a bagel and
I tell you what it feels like
I throw about that s alright okay they
don't look like that and Scotland they
don't need that while more chinny laughs
oh it's [ __ ] good easy as far my
hands kolesnik which incidentally is
also a happens you know that's my pork
pie
pork supposed to be pink in the middle
if it looks a bit pink and I've just
took quite a big bait over I mean I'm
always good at all for the penis shaped
snacks I just laughs I don't usually eat
anything because I'm too busy spewing up
so whatever I have the neighbor for is
usually I could start it and they I'll
probably get pizza or something and
because my mother's cooking
[ __ ] disgusts me if you're watching
mum [ __ ] sort your show
okay these are pork scratchings and
these ones are other nations favorite
master pork it sounds a bit dusty oh my
[ __ ] god
that horrible master four key as a
bullshitting bastard NIMS that sounds
far this is going to be a [ __ ] I toss
up for the shutter snaps these are just
all cakes
I [ __ ] hate both of these things on a
don't ride them Wow [ __ ] thick
cardboard there in the state and it's
dry as [ __ ]
I suppose unless the porky ones because
it's actually flavour OB it terrible
flavor you're not supposed to put stuff
on or kicks the first thing got aa
that makes sense I don't care a lot of
kettles
I don't really approach people in bars
either do you like PlayStation 4s that's
[ __ ] dreadful well as that's forged
ah cool dorieke and this is a comfort
see I've never had a moment before yeast
and extract not to be confused with a
yeast infection all that [ __ ] week
man
do you like my way we are very different
people that [ __ ] magnet not a fan of
MAME or polish but I am I would draw it
eat porridge it tastes of nothing than
my mail it tastes like Nate meals
I don't like shortbread as you can pull
a tail I'm not a fan of like haggis
because it means me like present food
next we've got and this is a Tunnock's
teacake which is a very Scottish thing
and this is shape mmm I thought so
Meghan Illinois
well how am i I don't like it there
neither oh yeah
not fine but I spare them with the tea
cake okay
yeah the tart ones has it not old we
still read a lot of books I'm from
Scotland so a Scotland one cotton one
thank you to our people for having me on
making meet my mate which is [ __ ] the
Devils are Jack youlet thank you very
much for having me on it
[Music]
you